welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul aka the throne in your
side and this video we're breaking down
a soccer episode 3.
the latest episode has just dropped on
Disney plus and it's packed with Easter
eggs hidden details and bigger
connections to the overall Star Wars
Universe throughout this video we're
going to be going through it all but if
you enjoy the video make sure you hit
that Thumbs Up Button And subscribe you
will for videos like this every day
without the way huge thank you for
clicking this now let's get into Ahsoka
Force resides in all living things
we have to prepare for
repair
I know you can do this is okay
let's go again so last week saw a
superstar Destroyer hyperdrive being
brought to the eye of Scion in order to
give Morgan ellisbeth a pathway to
thrawn based on the Jedi hyperdrive
Rings this would allow the Knight sister
to finally bring him back after he was
taken away in the rebels finale though
last week we thought Scion might be a
reference to Darth Sion its true
meanings probably more in line with the
literary meaning which defines the
mystical Utopia though it also shares
similarities to the word Scion which
also means air thrawn was known as the
head of the Empire showing that it's all
connected also lots of people have been
confused about the timeline because
they're telling Star Wars in a very
weird order I thought I'd just clarify
when this is before we go straight into
the video so people have more of an idea
when it takes place so Rebels set up
well a rebellion and then it had a Time
jump in the final few minutes of the
show that took us Post Battle of Endor
Sabine and Ahsoka then went off to find
Israel with us learning in this show
that they then potted ways Ahsoka then
popped up in the Mandalorian season 2
episode 5 where she caught Morgan and
then Mano continued on from that side by
side with his show I'm guessing at some
point we will encounter Luke and he may
even learn aware grogu was due to Ahsoka
meeting up with him Mano season 3 is yet
to happen as is the sequel Trilogy which
in the timeline is still decades at
hopefully that clears up all the
confusion and that takes us into the
episode 3 breakdown now the episode
begins with the T6 traveling through
hyperspace while we watch sabine's
training this mimics kendo's sticks at
Samurai's use and we also see hu Yang
busting at his forearms this is similar
to General Grievous and I'd love it if
at some point we've seen him busting out
those lightsabers on the wall now he
wants more put Sabine down and there's
definitely this idea that she needs to
get better and quickly the way things
end we're heading into a big battle next
week and this has actually been teased
by a lot of the trailers now who Yang
also calls her lady Ren which might be a
title that's possibly a not to her
mother ersa who appeared in the animated
shows Sabine is of course Mandalorian
like her mother as well and her training
will get her to a certain point but she
needs to be able to go beyond that in
order to become a Jedi either way Ahsoka
gets down a traditional visor and the
design here is also based on Japanese
Kendo ones it also slightly resembles
Marek's helmet potentially showing a
connection between the two Sabine says
she can't see but when you're a Jedi
this doesn't really matter Rogue one of
course that had a blind character in it
and Kanan was also blinded as well the
wires are being part of the training is
something that's essential and these
vices have popped up at numerous times
throughout the entire Saga this is
something that the Jedi uses it makes
them stop relying on their eyes and
actually reach out with their feelings
so they can sense what's around them
this forces them to tap into the force
and it's why both Luke and the
Younglings at the Jedi Temple did this
in the Saga I hate them alright man cook
calm down mate either way this is
clearly pushing Sabine to have to tap
into the force she's clearly not able to
really do this as Yu Yang says that
she's one of the worst people he's ever
come across when it comes to having
natural aptitude this could be seen with
her battle against Shin where she was
just wildly flailing the lightsaber
about like it was a baseball bat still
though the training must continue and I
think she'll become stronger the more
that she does it now Ahsoka also says
sense my intentions this is because
Force users can sense the intentions of
others and this is in order to predict
their next move one of the best examples
of this is in the classic the classic
fair best movie of all time the Last
Jedi when snoke senses kylo's murderous
intent but doesn't realize it was for
him Asoka also says anger and
frustration are quick to give power but
will imbalance you that's definitely the
gift in the curse of the dark side and
Ahsoka seems to sense it growing in
Sabine she says let's go again which I
think might be a reference to the
training scene in The Matrix though let
me know below now the end tree is title
time to fly which
they fly now
they fly now this has a triple meaning
as it's a very ship heavy episode a
soccer of course goes into space and we
also see as Sabine starts to embrace
things which allow her to quote unquote
fly now from here we cut to home one and
also see a group of a-wings no longer
donning the common red Rebel coloring
they've now got blue stripes to show the
new Republic leadership several Capital
ships also sail through space and Harris
had to meet the councilors led by
Monmouth mothma is a character they're
slowly having pop up more and more on
these shows and she's of course a legend
when it comes to the law interestingly
the character was actually introduced in
this very same room during the events
over 10 of the Jedi this is actually the
same ship that Akbar LED during the
Battle of Endor and it's now back to
being where they learn of the new great
threat I feel like those around her are
Aristocrats similar to the ones in Mando
and though they seem moronic in that
they were the ones who funded a lot of
the Rebellion efforts originally Mothman
was played by Caroline blackisten but
within your stuff she's played by
Genevieve O'Reilly in terms of release
order we last saw her in Ando but when
we look at the Timeline a last
appearance technically was in Return of
the Jedi it's also ziono which probably
butchered that pronunciation also I know
you guys like to correct pronunciations
here but if if you're watching this on
YouTube it might be too late to do that
either way that's a nice little
resistance Easter egg as I'm sure his
father was in it and speaking of
children we also get a reference to
Jason he pops up after the meeting with
Hera and it's so cool seeing him in live
action Jason is Hera's son who was
introduced at the end of the Clone Wars
and he also just happens to be the son
of Kanan jarus I always thought that
might be a reference to Jason solo which
was one of Hannah Leia's kids from the
expanded law that all happened before it
was wiped but Mt said that as well yeah
so it's kind of now it's it's actually
Canon again now the new Republic Senator
calls the defectors near outliers and
this makes it seem like the arrogance is
growing once more and the good guys that
cause that downfall in the first place
device error 2 is caught up in the
politics and finding it hard to get
resources and support which is something
that we've also seen in the Saga before
do you know so had to do an Ethan Hunt
and go Rogue and this is also why Leia
had to form a resistance on her own era
is basically in Leia's shoes at this
point getting rejected and you're not
allowed to do anything she talks about
thrawn says that he killed her friends
and also people that were family to her
this is likely a reference to her
romance with Kanan which was very
short-lived but they spent enough time
together to have that little kid now the
mood kind of changes when Hera brings
thrawn up and he's basically become bold
oh sorry he should he who shall not be
named in the Star Wars universe as for
thrawn just in case he's jumping on
without seeing Rebels or reading the
expanded law then you might be at a loss
for why everyone's really thrawny for
him we've had a couple of hints towards
him with his shadow Council watched him
dominate in Rebels and he is quite
important which is why all the
characters are still after him now
Throne is very much seen as the person
that will unite the Empire once more and
though others are trying to seize power
he's the best Contender for it now of
course we know the first order
eventually rise up and take power with
snow Cox and ren running into the
Palpatine's control however thrawn's
still a big player and the quote unquote
head of the Empire will probably be the
big bad of Dave baloney's movie first
mentioned in live action back in the
Mando Ahsoka episode she's obviously
been on the hunt for him due to him
being close to Ezra the cannon is kind
of all over the place for him as he's a
character who was in The Saga both
before and after the Disney acquisition
we've actually done a full breakdown on
him if you want to check that out which
will be linked just search for it mate
you know you know how to use the search
function don't you have you on the cliff
notes though he was called kivu raw Nuru
which was shortened to thrawn because no
one no one could spell at me and they
were writing hundreds of expanded lore
novels back in the day with no one was
bothering to check that anyway he was
born on rental which is located in the
unknown region of the Galaxy which I've
always thought they could call thrawn
Hub eh
yep hit and he became an officer of the
chess Academy and quickly Rose through
the ranks because of his ruthless and
strategic mind curious about what the
rest of the Galaxy entailed he traveled
out into other parts of space and this
is where he met Anakin Skywalker he
aided him in finding Padme one time and
fought alongside him during several of
the Clone Wars conflicts he joined the
Galactic Empire and the Royal Imperial
Academy eventually becoming known as the
grand Admiral thrawn was last seen
during the Battle of lothal where he and
Ezra were taken away and the pair have
remained there for most of the original
trilogy now I'd say Jason says that he
wants to become a Jedi and this would
mean that he follows in his Father's
Footsteps I think it would be great if
he started to do this as well and we
might see him go after Luke's Luke's
wonderful brimming Academy yay anyway
back with Sabine we see she wants to
rush through her training and patience
is of course a virtue with the Jedi Yoda
almost in train Luke because he didn't
feel like he had any but it was Obi-Wan
who managed to talk him around in the
end and she is trying at least and we
see her attempting to pull a cup towards
her as Huang says though very few
mandalorians have become a Jedi and it's
gonna be interesting to see where they
go with it now the first Mandalorian
Jedi was top Isla and he's actually the
character that made the darksaber this
is something that sabine's handle before
and looking at the Timeline I I think
it's now with Mando might still be with
moth Gideon but either way we see the T6
still out in hyperspace just in case you
missed our last video this first
appeared in the Clone Wars episode
Children of the force and though the t6s
are actually an older model it still
checks out now these were brought back
into circulation during the Clone Wars
and typically Jedi Fighters were used
but they were only able to produce so
many of these so they brought the T6
back normally they're completely
non-lethal and absent of weapons which
is synonymous with the thinkings of the
Jedi the Jedi teachings are of course
based around Eastern philosophies and
martial arts such as Judo and karate
their self-defense and this is carried
over to the Jedi with them often not
ever really going on the attack I've
actually been doing a big Empire Strikes
Back breakdown and I thought it was
interesting in that how all of Yoda's
training was about Luke either
meditating or rotting because he's gonna
need to run away from stuff anyway we
hear from Hera that she and the fleet
won't be joining her and this is purely
down to the politics of the new Republic
I kind of feel like the way the
transmission cuts off that you know it's
gonna alarm Hera and likely next week I
think they will probably show up and
rescue them either way they enter the
denab system where all comms are jammed
due to how secret Morgan wants to keep
the eye of Scion work at this point the
rambush by Shin Marek and a couple of
red shirts are they can kill off to make
the action scene seem more impactful say
that though I really really enjoyed this
bit and this dogfight of course riffs on
the one from A New Hope with Han and
Luke on the Falcon we even get lines
like whoa I got one but rather than
being told to stop being cocky Ahsoka
says
one good work really supportive there
and we can also see fighter pilot go on
one of the pilots making this more in
line with the one that shot up in the
Mandalorian that was actually giving it
out to the aerial fights from the Dam
Busters which themselves were based off
World War II cockpit footage that
inspired A New Hope and it's nice that
it gets brought across here to build
into this new chapter I hope you want to
support the channel we just launched in
Ahsoka on grago inspired T-shirt with a
quote from their first meeting in the
Mandalorian not only do they make you
look slicker than Amando and best score
but they also help support the channel
so videos like this can get made the
t-shirts are located just below the
video so if you want to check that out
it's just one click away and you will
click on the video because we're doing
the Jedi motion hand movement Shin also
says I have you now which is something
better said during the trench running A
New Hope Sabine freaks out over this
whole thing but we see how in this
situation ahsoka's more calm but Soca
has training which allows her to master
her attachments so she knows how to
calmly prioritize in high stress
situations also these ships look really
similar to Spitfires again pulling from
that Whole World War II aesthetic at
this point they catch the eye which
comes with laser cannon itself and this
is similar to what a lot of capital
ships have reminded me a lot of when the
Falcon comes across the Death Star for
the first time in a New Hope and there
is kind of that Wonder as they see the
size and scale of it we also see Marek
says As You Wish and throughout the
fight it seems like he takes orders from
Shin this might mean that Marek is
Shin's Apprentice but it also might yeah
it might might take us into time
the so in our video breakdown on episode
one and two we officially officially
said that Mara could be Ezra before
before Ryan did before we said it before
Ryan narrated now the guys promised me
that if it's right he'll actually credit
me with the entire Theory so I'm telling
you telling you what internet yeah I I
invented that theory he's a bloody
yeah but uh in the in the video anyway
we talked about things like how Sabine
has Ezra's lightsaber which would
explain why he needs The Inquisitor one
the meaning behind the word Marek and a
lot more in case you don't know Marek
was a knight from Arthurian Legend who
was actually turned into a wolf by a
witch this was Morgana lefe with Morgan
clearly being a play on the witch from
that Legend there's lots of Arthurian
imagery in this with Dark Knights and
also the round table aesthetic that they
have with the Hologram table Ezra Bean
turned into Marek by Morgan could be a
play on this and there are some other
Clues dotted about the episodes now Ezra
had a close connection to the loath
wolves so this may be how he gained the
name and looking at it like that that it
would make a lot of sense now people are
saying this Theory falls down because
Ezra was where thrawn was but who knows
with the way that pergol work and so on
they might have brought him back or
something and we may get the pickle from
season three of Mando connecting with
this in some way or another we also
don't know how they even got the star
map in the first place and in order for
someone to make that they have to have
known where thrawn was and then come
back from there might not be air
throughout but it is just a theory and
there have been other things people have
discussed this week about Mephisto so
sorry Marek he's definitely not another
Mephisto promise you that guys make sure
you keep watching a sandwich was name
actually appeared in the credits last
week and as we know he wasn't in the
last episode or was he well theories
have been abound that Whitworth is
actually the one behind the mask and
Marek might actually be Gala Marek AKA
Starkiller in case you don't know he's
the protagonist in The Force Unleashed
games but due to them having multiple
endings his face kind of all over the
place there were some instances where he
succumbed the dark side and became a
villain and I think it would make sense
if they kind of tapped into that
Starkiller is an absolute G as well and
I'm unsure whether this stuff's kind of
now in the wake of the Disney
acquisition it would be such a cool way
to bring the character across now wait
what actually talked about well not
talked about it because the strikes are
going on but here's what he said when he
was just going over things with Ahsoka
as it's part of the strike I can't
really talk about stuff like that except
for there's a show that I watched and I
really like The Syndicate members in the
area
I don't know what this the rules are I
mean honestly like I didn't I was just
about to say I didn't work on Ahsoka but
I did so I yeah I don't think I can say
anything guys but uh Prada Dave from The
Firm I love Dave now there's other ideas
that it's Baris offy but I'm not too
sure if we're too far away from the arc
she had in Clone Wars his symbol was
seen in the Mandalorian so maybe that's
a possibility but at the moment the
internet seems to be either with Ezra or
whitwear now it could just be them
referencing his name in the credits or
it could be something else going on
where it has done a lot of different
characters in Star Wars including vocal
work so to be fair it may be just that I
actually think right I actually think
it's a pretty big character from The
Saga and that it's none other than
[Music]
yeah that's right go up oh is
finally making a big appearance and
that's the end of two time due time
pizza time
now the T6 ends up dead in space which
forces Ahsoka to go into the vacuum
herself I think the last time we saw
lightsaber action in space like this was
during the Star Wars Visions episode the
twins though they didn't wear suits in
that like Ahsoka does again though this
carries the new Republic blue and again
I've got to keep saying it really
enjoyed this moment now the fightier
also evokes Rey doing the same thing to
kylo's tie in episode 9 and this has
been one of my favorite moments in the
series so far as they head down to the
planet we watches a pot of pearl come up
from the clouds and to the best of my
knowledge this is the first time we've
witnessed them in live action in all
their Glory another was seen in Mando
season 3 but this is our first proper
look up close and yeah it completely
blew me away seeing this in live action
at least space whales are able to jump
through hyperspace and originally they
were used to map out hyperspace Lanes
based off their migration before nav
computers were developed four sensitive
Travelers used to use their sensors to
feel out when it was safe to exit
hyperspace so they wouldn't end up in of
a planet or in the middle of a heavy
spoilers video those who couldn't use
the force would follow the pear girl and
this would help Travelers map out the
Galaxy and they're embedded in a hell of
a lot of things in the series
surrounding the connection of thrawn and
Ezra they also appeared on the star map
in episode 2 and we could catch them in
a ring around the locator this was
similar to The Wolves around the world
between World stowaway and they were
used to indicate a doorway here as well
either way so cool seeing them in live
action like this and you know it was a
bit of a shock to be honest and seen
them pop up like this with their grace
and beauty I was like yeah you know what
that's really cool now being fascinated
by them something Marek shares too and
he actually seems like he gets
distracted by them if this is indeed
Ezra that would make a lot of sense as
this is something that he'd know from
his previous life however let's just say
he's a standard Inquisitor then the
grunt in Anger he feels at losing the T6
makes sense too inquisitors were of
course Jedi Hunters so losing out on
Ahsoka would be extremely annoying for
him anyway after the chase we get the
scan of the eye and explanation of it
who Yang mentions to Jedi archives
having information on Intergalactic
hyperspace lanes and these were mapped
out by following pergol migration paths
the credits animations seem to be one of
those Jedi Maps linking both of these
moments together now in with bale in
ordering his goons to hunt them down in
the forest but it is quite interesting
that he doesn't go himself in the
previous episode he mentioned how it
would be a shame to kill Ahsoka as
there's few Jedi left and this might
show that he could in fact be turned we
still don't know too much about his past
but we have had some clues about what's
going on due to a couple of lines here
and there you mentioned Anakin speaking
highly of Ahsoka and also gave the idea
that he'd study at the Jedi Temple or at
least encounter the Younglings there the
children of the Jedi Temple called it
that comes from old stories
I hate them abelin also has a close tie
demaric as to Shin as we mentioned
before the name Marek has a title wolves
and that's the same when it comes to the
pair balin's full name is balin's Skull
and skulls the wolf in Norse mythology
that chases the sun on the other side of
this his apprentice's name is Hadi which
is said to be the wolf that chases the
moon Dave filoni right is absolutely
obsessed with wolves and even his
character Amanda was called Trapper wolf
now throughout the week I actually saw
some concept art which came from the
canceled Star Wars Battlefront 3 and 4
games these contained alternate versions
of characters including one of the dark
Obi-Wan that I actually think might be
the basis for Balin might be a big reach
but just looking at the design you can
see a lot of similarities to how he
appeared in episode one kind of feel
that Shin might end up betraying him and
they'll become more in line with the
Sith who are known for their
backstabbing while side stabbing if he
can't snoke anyway they're not really
safe nor Jedi they're just force
sensitive characters trying to carve out
a place for themselves you can actually
see that shin has a Padawan braid
showing that she's being trained like a
Jedi because that's where baleen would
know most of his knowledge from Shin is
far more aggressive than Baylen though
and it is going to be interesting to see
where things go from here after a slow
start with those first two episodes I
feel like this really got things going
and it was way more interesting than I I
found those to be another run time was
shorter and I heard this before was
released which looking back it actually
left me a bit worried Disney Plus shows
yeah they do a lot of weird runtime
stuff and the shorter episodes are
normally the ones that aren't as good I
was worried that they hadn't learned
their lessons but I think this worked
out quite well I'm not sure if the
show's Gonna Save Star Wars but looking
at this I I did actually enjoy which is
a big flip from last week because yeah
if you listen to my review on that then
you'll know I was quite disappointed now
it was nice seeing peregal and also the
focus on the two sides and the
characters rather than them simply
chasing after a MacGuffin which I feel
the first two are guilty of now the
vegan Figures were released by Samba TV
this week and to be honest you know
they're not terrible but they're not as
good as you would expect them to be in
the first six days the premiere was
watched by 1.2 million households in the
US and comparing this to She-Hulk that
was watched by 1.5 that was in the first
four days and House of the Dragon was
also viewed by 4.8 million in the first
four as well so Ahsoka had two extra
days two episodes drop and didn't really
come close to what it should have been
with it being a big Star Wars show now I
want to put the question over to you of
why you think that is do you think the
show will get more popular or is this
just a state of Star Wars and where the
fandom is in general comment below with
your thoughts and if there's anything
that we missed as well then make sure
you drop that too please hit the thumbs
up button and if you want to support the
channel as a member of the spoiler
Society then please click the join
button you'll get early access to videos
every week such as that Empire Strikes
Back one and it goes such a long way to
helping us out now if you want to else
to watch we've got a video on screen
right now talking about lots of things
connected to Star Wars in Ahsoka that
video by Mt that we talked about before
he's done a really good job on it yet
head over there after this and make sure
you check that out well out of the way
huge thank you for sync through the
video I'll be important I'll see you
next time take care peace